[Musik]
ein gewaltvideo über das ganz
Deutschland spricht junge Mädchen fast
noch Kinder treten prügeln auf eine
Schülerin ein schockierende Brutalität
wie analysieren hier die Frage werden
Mädchen immer brutaler das heute ein
Thema hier bei uns bei viertel nach acht
und ich freue mich auf diese Gäste Arzt
und Bestsellerautor Gunther Frank sagt
ganz klar stoppt die corona-impfung er
sieht in der Impfung eine tödliche
Gefahr mieten wird für immer mehr
Menschen unbezahlbar deshalb fordert die
Linken Politikerin kathina Schubert ein
radikales Umdenken der Staat müsste
endlich eingreifen und verstärkt selber
bauen und die wichtigen und Mächtigen
der Welt die treffen sich aktuell in
Davos dort werden die Weichen für die
Zukunft gestellt von wegen mein Polizist
Hendrik im Bruder er hält von diesem
Event in einem kleinen Schweizer
Bergdorf absolut nichts
nach langem Hin und Her die CDU jetzt
auch ihre Liebe für die Kernkraft
entdeckt das Motto Kernenergie ist
Klimaschutz wurde ausgerufen warum das
so ist das erklärt uns heute der
Hamburger CDU-Chef Christoph floss und
ich habe es gerade schon angesprochen
jetzt schauen wir uns dieses Video auch
an über das ganz Deutschland spricht
zwei 13-jährige Mädchen schlagen brutal
auf eine 14-Jährige ein sehen Sie diese
Bilder sie treten mit den Füßen das
Mädchen des Landes mit schweren
Verletzungen im Krankenhaus und
drumherum stehen Passanten Film schauen
zu aber keiner greift ein
was schockiert mehr worüber ist man fast
mehr entsetzt über die Brutalität der
Mädchen oder darüber dass niemand hilft
Herr Bruder
ich weiß nicht ich mag auch das Video
nicht gucken weil ich das so gruselig
finde für mich stellt sich nicht die
Frage wer da schuldig oder noch
Schuldiger ist ich finde es einfach das
ist eine kleine Fußnote zu der Verrohung
die wir seit langem erleben darüber gibt
es viele Spekulation woher die Verrohung
kommt erstmal hat es was mit dem
empowerment zu tun das was Frauen aus
dem Parlament machen ist vermutlich auch
davon abhängig aus welchen Milieus sie
kommen in der Unterschied macht das
vielleicht tatsächlich in der Form von
einem powerment sein fürchte ich und das
zweite ist dass niemand eingreift diese
Gesellschaft ist so gründlich
pazifiziert worden dass Leute an der
Gewalt vorbeischauen es genügt nicht nur
darüber hinwegzusehen dass die Ukraine
massakriert wird wir schauen auch weg
wenn der Nachbarskind zusammengeschlagen
wird das sind für mich die unmittelbaren
Folgen des gesellschaftlichen Pazifismus
das ist gar nicht Herr Dr Frank so weit
weg von ihnen das sind Badener
Württemberg in Rastatt wirklich auch in
der Provinz hätten sie das dort erwartet
oder vermutet man solche Bilder nicht
eher aus dem Großstädten
nein ich glaube Leute die in dem Bereich
also professionell arbeiten dann erleben
das schon auch dass diese Hemmschwelle
einfach auch sinkt
das ist glaube ich schon eine
allgemeines Problem ich meine das war
wirklich Dritte gegen den Kopf also der
ist schon der tötungskuppel eigentlich
schon
sehr tief wo ich mal sagen man kann es
kaum ertragen das haben wir hier gerade
auch gesagt Frau Schubert diese Bilder
die wir da gerade gesehen haben und die
Kinder und Jugend Brutalität die steigt
an in den vergangenen fünf Jahren
besonders unter den äh 14-jährigen junge
Kinder hätten sie eingegriffen trauen
wir uns nicht mehr einzugreifen wenn man
da in diesem Bahnhof steht und so eine
Szene beobachtet
also ich finde dieses Video auch
schockierend und ich glaube ich hätte
eingegriffen also schon aus einem Impuls
raus weil ich das auch jetzt bei mir
merke und Geduld und natürlich auch
sofort die Polizei gerufen ich kann es
gar nicht verstehen dass man das filmt
aber nichts tut das kann ich wirklich
nicht verstehen ich fürchte
wir haben es auch mit einem mit so einer
also das wirkt ja so ein bisschen als
wollten den Computerspielen nachspielen
ja und diese diese diese verschwinden
zwischen Realität und dem was man
irgendwie zu Hause irgendwie am
Computerbildschirm macht das scheint mir
auch für viele ein Problem zu sein also
dass da Realität und und Spiel völlig
ähm
völlig ineinander verschwimmen und man
überhaupt nicht mehr dass diese Empathie
hat Schmerz zu empfinden und auch zu
empfinden dass andere Schmerzen haben
das ist ja über die dieses Mädchen am
Boden das hat wahrscheinlich brüllende
Schmerzen hat schwere Verletzungen und
das ist da nicht mehr diese natürliche
Hemmschwelle gibt aufzuhören
das finde ich ist ein riesen Problem ich
meine das ist jetzt kein tägliche
Geschichte und ich glaube es hat auch
nichts mit Frauen in powerment zu tun in
dieser Apotheke Geschichte es wird noch
nicht täglich berichtet täglichen
Brutalität wahrscheinlich nicht aber
diese Tendenz zur Verrohung die sehe ich
auch die sehe ich auch und ich glaube es
hat auch was damit zu tun dass man genau
solche Fragen von
aufeinander achten
Wertschätzung dass das auch zu wenig
eine Rolle spielt und dass diese diese
dieser pausenlose Druck und gleichzeitig
so eine gewisse Vereinsamung vor Medien
dieses dieses Empathie dieses
gemeinsame sprechen
Sie eine Erklärung dafür hätten sie
eingegriffen das muss man sich auch
trauen viele sagen oh weh ich habe Angst
dass ich da selber verletzt werde oder
dass ich damit rein hätten sie
eingegriffen was hätten sie getan also
zumindest wäre das mein Anspruch da
einzugreifen das ist jetzt immer etwas
hypothetisch zu sagen was hätte man
gemacht man ich kenne jetzt ja genauso
wie alle hier in der Runde und nur diese
Video Schnipsel und diese Ausschnitte
nicht das was drumherum geschehen ist
aber das sollte zumindest der Anspruch
eines jeden Bürgers sein in Deutschland
dann da auch einzugreifen und dazwischen
zu gehen oder zumindest schnell die
Polizei zu rufen und andere auch zu
aktivieren anstatt so etwas auch noch zu
finden
was ist da jemand gefehlt hat finde ich
sehr begrüßenswert auf diese Weise App
für mich erst oder helfe ich erst ne
also nein die Frage hat sich dadurch
schon beantwortet dass sie gefilmt hat
wenn er erst hilft und dann anfängt zu
viel man ist Situation vorbei aber was
ich gerne wissen möchte weiß man was mit
den Hintergrund woher kommen diese
Mädchen was wir hatten Erziehung hatten
sie und alles
ich wollte einfach nur noch einen ein
Punkt Mann der wichtig ist weil das ist
ja ein Fall der auch möglicherweise für
viele andere Fälle in Deutschland steht
und häufig ist auch der Umgang dann mit
solchen Gewalttätern mit solchen
Straftätern zu lasch da werden nicht
Grenzen aufgezeigt und das Signal was
auch gerade an gewaltbereite Jugendliche
geht ist häufig ihr könnt das machen ihr
kommt dann sowieso schnell wieder frei
oder ist passiert nicht und das animiert
natürlich einige auch noch so brutal
vorzugehen und deswegen glaube ich muss
der Rechtsstaat auch solchen
gewaltbereiten Jugendlichen her schon
deutlicher die Grenzen aufzeigen ist es
jetzt ein neuer Erkenntnis für die CDU
na für die CDU gar nicht wir haben das
ja selber auch in vielen Bundesländern
umgesetzt und so gehandelt das war immer
etwas was wir gefordert haben ich komme
ja aus Hamburg da haben wir das selber
ja erlebt wir waren zur Jahrtausendwende
Hauptstadt des Verbrechens das war
damals das unheimliche Schlagwort was
ich der SPD Senat erarbeitet hatte und
dann haben wir genau da auch viel härter
agiert und gesagt der Rechtsstaat darf
sich so etwas nicht gefallen lassen und
die Zahlen sind dann auch zurückgegangen
das können Sie auch in anderen Ländern
sehen also zum Beispiel Bayern ist da
auch immer sehr konsequent aber leider
wird das nicht überall so praktiziert
gerade hier in Berlin jetzt um
13-jährige Mädchen da greift gar keinen
Staatsrecht da sind tatsächlich Hilfe zu
Erziehung dringend angesagt ohne
Überprüfung wie konnte es dazu kommen
warum sind 13-jährige Mädchen in der
Lage so etwas zu tun
entschuldigung das ist üblicher begriff
dass da
[Musik]
entsprechend erstens geguckt wird aus
welchem Elternhaus kommen sie braucht es
da Unterstützung des Elternhauses
braucht es möglicherweise eine
Unterbringung nie so viele
Erziehungshilfe gegeben hat wie heute
noch nicht so vieles Sozialarbeiter
Helfer Familienhelfer
eben nicht genug geht es ist nie genug
es ist nie genug für diese Gesellschaft
kann es gar nicht genug Sozialarbeiter
geben und das ist kein neues Phänomen
neu ist das eine gewisse Intensität in
der Berichterstattung stattfindet es
werden unglaublich viele Sachen unter
den Teppich geklärt und das gilt auch
leider für mein Gewerbe in diesem Dorf
wie ist das Ziel Ibbenbüren Illertissen
nein ich meine das andere sehen sie so
viel Auswahl haben wir schon an diesem
Tag bestanden hat einen 17-jähriger
Schüler seine Lehrerin gestochen und
dann hat die Polizei angerufen bis jetzt
wissen wir nichts über die Hintergründe
wieso bleibt die Öffentlichkeit still
wenn Sie nicht über solche Vorfälle
informiert werden das passiert laufend
ich glaube was uns hier auch an diesem
Tisch ein mehr Zivilcourage denn dann
hätte das Kind ist im Krankenhaus
gelandet mit schweren Verletzungen wurde
inzwischen wieder entlassen Gott sei
Dank aber es hätte
Positionen
Courage wird in Deutschland mit Preisen
belohnt aber es gibt keine selbst die
Polizei rät nicht dazwischen zu gehen
und vorher noch 110 anzurufen
Zivilcourage in diesem Land ist eine
solchen Seltenheit wie der Mut sich
gegen die vorher schon der Meinung zu
stellen
muss sich gegen vorherrschende Meinung
Zustände sind wir nämlich jetzt oder ich
gehe direkt rein in ihr Zimmer hat und
Frank das genau haben sie nämlich
gemacht sie haben während der
corona-pandemie der Regierung immer ganz
genau auf die Finger geschaut haben
gewarnt wurden dafür auch stark
kritisiert sie sagen jetzt die Impfung
die ist brandgefährlich sie stützen sich
dabei auf Obduktionen das ist ihr Thema
das ist ihre Zeit
ja also wir haben ja seit den 60er
Jahren seit dem Konter ganz Skandal
zufriedenstellende Zulassungen für neue
Medikamente entwickelt wir haben auch
Sicherheitssystem entwickelt um
danebenwirkungen rechtzeitig zu
entdecken und diese Sicherheitssysteme
für neue Arzneimittel sind seit der
corona-krise quasi hinweggefegt worden
ja es werden Zulassungsstudien
akzeptiert die gefälscht sind die meiner
Meinung nach korrupt sind die ist gerade
Gegenteil behaupten als das was wirklich
drin steht dafür dass Medikament
zugelassen dann werden rechtlich
vorgeschriebene Sicherheitssysteme von
Paul ehrlichen Institut ignoriert ja
seit zwei Jahren werden die Vorgaben des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes mit den
Krankenkassen Daten die die Meldungen zu
vergleichen
ignoriert die Daten sind eindeutig ja
wir haben ein riesen Sicherheitsprobleme
mit dieser Impfung aber diejenigen die
das dann auch bekannt machen werden dann
vom Bundestag ausgelacht ich will ganz
klar sagen wir werden auch die impfopfer
von den Parlamentariern ausgelacht und
was macht der Gesundheitsminister
rennt in Davos rum als die Verkörperung
der German Angst ja als einziger trägt
er dort eine Maske und redet dort wirres
Zeug im Sinne von jahrhundert der
Pandemien und wir haben hier ein Arznei
mittelproblem ja und ich sitze jeden Tag
Patienten gegenüber ich muss Ihnen
erklären warum sie in Zukunft neuartigen
Medikamenten nicht mehr vertrauen dürfen
weil sie Freiwild geworden sind für ja
profitgetriebene Interessen die
offensichtlich die Behörden der
durchseucht haben und eins müssen wir
wissen wenn wir sicherer Arzneimittel
wollen in Deutschland besonders die
Neuzulassungen dann müssen die
Verantwortlichen zur Rechenschaft
gezogen werden und Sie müssen vor
Gericht stehen und das erhoffe ich mir
von für den nächsten Jahren dass das
passiert das war eine ganz schöne
Ansprache ich will da einmal noch in die
Tiefe gehen laut im Register lassen sich
immer noch bis zu 23.000 Menschen
täglich gegen Corona impfen
welche Gefahr droht ihnen und auf welche
Quellen berufen sie sich da ja es ist
einfach fürchterlich die diese Menschen
vertrauen halt einfach immer noch der
Regierung Vertrauen auch den
wissenschaftsverbänden aber die Zahlen
sind wirklich verrückt wir sehen die
Anstiege von neuen Todesfällen da wird
immer gesagt ja das kann man nicht
beweisen dass es ursächlich damit
zusammenhängt darum geht es nicht es
geht um Warnsignale das übrigens auch
ein Phänomen der amerikanischen CDC da
hat wurde gerade aufgedeckt dass die CDC
das was sie als nationale
Sicherheitssystem macht das ist
vergleichbar mit der Zulassungsbehörde
in Deutschland dass die diese schlagen
zahlen einfach unterschlagen haben es
ist es ist eine Riesenskandal man lässt
die Leute ins offene Messer Rennen ich
habe lediglich fast täglich Probleme ja
das ist ein ganz typische Beschwerden
nach der Impfung geht's los mit
kribbelnden komischen Hautproblemen
manchmal geht die Kraft Weg das kann so
weit gehen dass die Leute im Rollstuhl
sitzen sie haben Herzrhythmusstörungen
sie haben brustdruck sie werden in den
Notaufnahme werden abgewimmelt dann
heißt es lungenkurve das ist nicht nur
Kurve die Physiologie des mRNA Begriff
ist ganz klar das war von Anfang an klar
dass das ein Hochrisiko Medikament ist
und das sehen wir jetzt einfach und es
wird einfach
ignoriert in die Leute werden weiter ans
Messer geliefert das ist ein
Riesenskandal und der muss aufgearbeitet
werden weil ich will wieder sicherer
Medikamente haben ich will wieder in
einer Medizin arbeiten die Verantwortung
trägt und so geht es gerade nicht weiter
ehrlich nicht der Platz sie haben im
Bundestag für die Impfpflicht gestimmt
wenn sie jetzt Herrn Dr Frank sprechen
also das habe ich nicht weil wir hatten
ja mal wir hatten ja die nee wir hatten
ja die Debatte aber es gab am Ende ja
keine Abstimmung bzw es gab keinen
Antrag der durchgekommen ist
ich war nicht dafür ich habe damals
gesagt wenn wir sicherstellen können
dass wir mit einer Impfpflicht dafür
sorgen dass es keine lockdowns mehr gibt
und die Kollateralschäden die wir damals
erlebt haben verändert werden dann kann
man in der Abwägung für eine Impfpflicht
sein aber das natürlich auch eine
Debatte die jetzt heute gar nicht mehr
aktuell ist
was ich meine was was ich aber schon für
sehr wichtig finde und da will ich auch
wirklich klar widersprechen weil das
nach meinem Kenntnisstand eigentlich
alle Wissenschaftler auch weltweit
übereinstimmt sagen dass natürlich
alle Wissenschaften
Ornithologen
beginnt
sie mal nehmen Sie mal ein Beispiel und
Virologe sehr schätze den Hendrik der ja
selber auch gesagt hat so man muss immer
auch alles im Blick haben man darf das
nicht nur rein virologisch betrachten
sondern muss immer auch abwägen aber
auch der sagt natürlich ist es sinnvoll
sich impfen zu lassen genauso wie andere
Virologen oder andere Wissenschaftler so
und wir sehen
aber kurz einmal nur den Gedanken so
jetzt nehmen wir machen wir mal den
Lackmustest schauen wir mal nach China
die Chinesen haben das ja nicht
besonders gut hinbekommen dass die
Bevölkerung durchgeimpft ist so und da
sterben jeden Tag im Moment tausende
Menschen oder sehr sehr viele Menschen
weil die Menschen nicht geimpft sind
oder ein ganz schlechten Impfstoff haben
und in den Ländern wurde sehr hoch ist
da in Ländern in denen die Impfquote
sehr hoch ist diese Länder sind auch
besser durch die Pandemie gekommen so
und deswegen ist der präsentieren hier
ein katastrophalen Informationen stand
das stimmt hinten und vorne nicht
schauen sich die infektionssterblichkeit
Informationsstand stimmt also sie
spekulieren
die diese Beschwerden haben auch auf
wahrscheinlich bei jedem Impfstoff vor
dass Menschen das vertragen oder auch
nicht vertragen so wie kann vorher
medikam
wir haben ein Versuch am lebendigen
Objektiv Prozent der Bevölkerung gut
vertragen
gemeinsam
spielen mit zahlen wenn man 100 Flügen
10 tödlich enden würden würde die
Fluggesellschaft sofort einen Flugverbot
bekommen 10% wär schon wahnsinnig viel
das einzige was wir nicht wissen ist wie
hoch der Anteil der Erkrankung und der
Todesfälle ist an der gesamtseite
Impfungen und kommen Sie mir nicht mit
China weil China hat eine betrugspolitik
Betrieben vom ersten Tag an die haben
nach einem Jahr eine who-delegation an
den Ort gelassen oder das Virus
entstanden sein könnte nach einem Jahr
oder eine andere Debatte nein das kann
sich doch entschuldigen
da brauche ich nur in die Bild-Zeitung
zu gucken oder in die Welt bitte bitte
ganz klar drin und das andere
die Chinesen im Moment riesige Probleme
haben weil die Bevölkerung zu wenig
geimpft
hatten es gab zwei Länder mit einer
unheimlich hohen Impfquote Portugal und
Israel und in beiden hat trotzdem
Impfquote das Virus gnadenlos
zugeschlagen es gibt dazwischen deine
verbindliche Korrelation nicht so stark
wie in Ländern
und Bulgarien stehen gut da aber ist es
das Grundproblem ist doch dass die
Wissenschaft überhaupt keine Chance
hatte die wird dir aufgepocht haben sie
nicht gehört worden ausgegrenzt worden
wir haben eine infektionssterblichkeit
gestellt ja die einer mittleren Krippe
entspricht sogar für die eigentlich ist
die bedroht dieses Virus nur die älteren
ja wenn man den Fokus auf dem wenn man
das wenn man wenn man den Fokus auf die
Altersheim ja dann hätten wir darüber
reden können aber es war vollkommen
irrsinnig die unter 70-jährigen zu ihm
von vorkommen
sie haben da überhaupt die haben der
Todeszahlen die sind gegen 0 bei bei den
jungen Menschen und die in diese Risiko
informativ sind sogar Kinder gestorben
angucken Stück laut RKI alle schwer
vorerkrankt wollen sie mich jetzt ja
veräppeln also was was reden sie für
aber danke
allen unterstellen sie reden Unsinn nur
weil sie anderer Meinung sind als sie
deswegen auskenne was sie offensichtlich
nicht tun das ist das Problem
Mediziner Verbände sich auch alles Leute
die sich nicht empfehlen nämlich die
Impfungen die Impfung weil die sagen da
verhindert man sehr viele schwere Fälle
und man verhindert häufig auch
Todesfälle die deswegen empfehlen die
Ärzteverbände die Impfung also die
intensivlocke da muss man noch mal
getrennte Übersprechen und die falschen
Meldungen die gemacht haben Tatsache ist
und das hatte ersparen beauftragt das
wäre das die Bundesregierung ab April 21
dass wir eine historische Unterbelegung
auf den Intensivabteilung hat das ist
Fakt steht bei Ihnen auf dem
Bundesgesundheitsminister in Düsseldorf
auf dem Ministerium auf der Homepage
sparen verursache veranlasst da steht
das drin sie hatten Unterbelegung seit
die ganze corona-zeit haben wir
Unterbelegung in den Krankenhäusern wo
ist denn da bitte schön die Katastrophe
also diese Impfung wurde gepusht von
Anfang an und es ist ein wirklich ein
Menschheitsverbrechen was da gerade
passiert das muss es gestoppt werden
also ist sterben ganz viele weil die
geimpft sind also wollen sie das
ernsthaft hier erzählen natürlich also
wir müssen unterscheiden
zwischen Lockdown und ebenfalls muss
noch genau ermittelt werden wo halt
Übersterblichkeit kommt sie mehr haben
im letzten Dezember hatten wir 19 %
Übersterblichkeit im Vergleich zu den
vor Jahren ein bisschen rauskriegen ob
es der Lockdown war oder die Impfung
aber die waren Signale dass die Impfung
eine sehr großen Teil davon ausmachen
doch da wie kann man denn jetzt die die
Zulassung noch weiterlaufen lassen es
ist komplettes aus
das ist jetzt was ihr jetzt betreiben
wirklich zahlen Fetischismus wenn wir
uns eine halbe Stunde zurückziehen
doch Frau esken hat vor paar Wochen noch
in eine Sendung des ZDF gesagt wir haben
ein Experiment gemacht mit 4 Milliarden
Probanden und es gab gar keine
Nebenwirkungen von der haben sie glaube
ich noch die Zahlen nicht verlangt aber
das ist jetzt was anderes mit Zahlen
kann man sehr gut durch die über den
Zahlen also das kann ich überlegen sagen
alle Ärzteverbände Intensivmediziner
Virologen Leute die sich auskennen
und die Impfung kann schwere Verläufe
verhindern
haben 900.000 Leute unterschrieben und
professionell aus medizinischen Berufen
ja von Harvard und Professoren die haben
von Anfang an gewarnt sie wurden sogar
bei Twitter gesperrt ja also das ist
eine ist ein unglaubliches Skandal es
gibt genügend Leute die ernsthaft und
genau davor gewarnt haben und sie wurden
diskriminiert der Herr sonnigsten ist
gekündigt worden in Wien ja also wenn
sie sagen alle Wissenschaftler haben sie
offensichtlich nur die auf die gehört
die man ihnen interessant sagen sie dann
zu China im Moment da sind die Leute ja
zum Großteil nicht geimpft oder ganz
schwach geimpft wollen Sie jetzt von mir
wissen was keine Ahnung glauben sie
irgendeiner Zahl die aus China kommt
nach
rossmahlzeitung zu schauen
Sie Ihre Informationen aus der Zeitung
okay alles klar Information ich äußere
mich nicht auskenne
meine vielleicht hat man in ihrer Partei
von dem Beruf noch nichts gehört nicht
wahr aber
es ist wirklich unterirdisch und das
wissen sie
von ihnen gesagt sie sind komplimen Sie
bitte noch mal wir haben jahrelang in
einem gaune wie Dieter dem nebenan
gesessen und hat mir nichts ausgemacht
haben
schon gesagt alle Impfstoffe die
zugelassen sind Herr Bruder sind wirksam
und okay das haben sie gesagt am 23
April beim Parteitag 2021 auch wenn uns
klar geworden ist im Zuge dieser Sendung
dass sie nicht der Meinung sind von Dr
Frank findet trotzdem bei Ihnen einen
Umdenken statt in dem Sinne dass sie
sagen ich würde die Aussage so nicht
mehr treffen und ich finde wir müssen
uns das genauer anschauen ich habe jetzt
ehrlich gesagt nicht mitgekriegt was sie
zitiert haben
ich sag's noch einmal nein
alle Impfstoffe die zugelassen sind sind
wirksam und okay
würden Sie diesen Satz heute so sagen
oder würden Sie eine haben Sie eine
andere Sensibilität
also nach 40 Jahren Pandemie habe ich
natürlich eine andere Sensibilität auch
noch mal um zu überprüfen was waren
richtige Maßnahmen was waren vielleicht
überzogene Maßnahmen der ganzen
Auseinandersetzung um den Lockdown
welche Maßnahmen Schulschließungen Kita
Schließungen was glaube ich wirklich
viel gravierendere gesellschaftliche
Folgen hatte als die Frage der
Impfstoffe ich sag das noch mal ich
glaube ich glaube sofort dass es
Menschen gibt denen das Impfen überhaupt
nicht bekommen ist und die
Nebenwirkungen haben so wie andere
Menschen bei Medikamenten Nebenwirkungen
haben die vielleicht auch noch gar nicht
bekannt waren und die trotzdem
auftauchen können weil da ist jeder
Mensch anders aber das so zu
generalisieren wie es Herr Dr Frank
macht da habe ich meine Zweifel und er
hat mir noch keinen Beweis vorgelegt
dass das wirklich eine massenhaftes
Phänomen ist deswegen bezweifle ich
nicht einen einzigen Einzelfall und
daraus eine Strategie zu machen dass das
Impfen an sich schädlich ist das finde
ich politisch falsch weil das Impfen war
tatsächlich der Weg um aus dem Lockdown
rauszukommen aus diese fatalen
Schulschließungen und kita-schließungen
rauszukommen um wieder ein
gesellschaftliches Leben in dieser
Situation der Pandemie zu organisieren
dass man übrigens für viele andere
Krankheiten also viele Krankheiten in
der Menschheitsgeschichte wurden nur
besiegt und bekämpften
alle Impfungen
konfrontiert deswegen bin ich halt auch
so emotional dass ich würde es
eigentlich gar nicht erzählen ich würde
das gar nicht als irgendwo bezeichnen
davon abgesehen aber ist der Punkt ist
der und das ist jetzt wirklich sehr
wichtig nicht ich muss beweisen dass das
stimmt was ich sagen sondern die
zulassen Behörden müssen beweisen dass
die dass der Verdacht nicht stimmt und
da gibt's ein gesetzlichen Auftrag des
paul-ehrliche Institut hat
gesetzlich festgeschriebene
infektionsgeschützt gesetzt die Aufgabe
die Daten der Krankenkassen abzurufen
und zu analysieren es verweigert diesen
Auftrag seit zwei Jahren und die Leute
nur noch ein Fehler zulassen
aber sie geht damit das Risiko ein ja
dass die Menschen diesen riesigen
ausgesetzt werden und deswegen frage ich
sie auch als Parlamentarier was machen
sie damit dass paul Ehrlich Institut
endlich sein gesetzlichen Auftrag
nachkommt ja wo ist ihre Initiative
wollen sie das alles da AFD überlassen
ja ich meine wo sind sie also eigentlich
also sie sind ja irgendwie so ein
Pappkameraden auf den gar nicht gibt
also ich habe selber ich will ja gerade
darauf eingehen ist ein bisschen
schwierig wenn Sie nach einem Wort
sofort wieder kommen sie so können sie
aber in der Demokratie auch nicht
diskutieren wenn sie sowieso der Meinung
sind sie haben nur recht und ihre
Meinung anders okay ich sie sollten wir
schon in der Demokratie überlassen wie
ich meine Sätze anfangen das lasse ich
mir nicht von anderen viel Demokratie
gesagt jetzt würde ich aber gerne was
sagen also natürlich müssen wir uns
damit beschäftigen gibt es irgendwo
Impfschäden gibt es irgendwo auch Fälle
aus dem man Schlussfolgerung ziehen muss
und ich bin auch sehr dafür dass wir
ernst nehmen dass es immer noch auf
viele in Deutschland gibt die Sorgen
haben die auch das Impfen ablehnen und
die Ängste haben so und darauf muss man
eingehen und auch mit den Instituten
werden wir im Moment auch eine
Diskussion eher bezogen auf das weit
kochinstitut ob das nicht mehr so stark
auch anders Gesundheitsministerium
angedockt sein soll sondern eher auch
eine eigenständige Behörde sein soll das
finde ich seinen Ansatz den wir
insgesamt gerade im Gesundheitsbereich
vorantreiben sollten und das gilt dann
natürlich auch für andere Institute also
insofern bin ich auch sehr dafür und sag
jetzt nicht man soll diese Sorgen nicht
ernst nehmen
ist dass man sagt man hat irgendwo
vielleicht Fälle bei denen auch das im
anderen schädlich war umgekehrt haben
wir aber ganz viele Fälle bei denen das
Impfen hilfreich war und daraus jetzt zu
sagen schlusszufolgern naja impfen ist
grundsätzlich schädlich und hilft nicht
um das Corona-Virus zu werden wenn
ja
ich habe damit sehr gute Erfahrungen
gemacht bei mir gab es auch keine
Nebenwirkungen und ich bin bisher auch
ganz gut durch die Pandemie gekommen und
glaube auch dass das Impfen da geholfen
hat so wie auch irgendwie den anderen
genau am Ende
eine Flasche Scheibe ist
wieso es gibt doch aber es gibt doch
insgesamt viele Analysen ich habe ja
eben auch Ärzteverbände und so genannt
die sagen mit dem Impfen kann man sehr
sehr viele Fälle verändern die auf der
Intensivstation landen oder die dann
sterben das natürlich weiß man im
Einzelfall nie genau was wäre wenn ja
weil sie eben den Einzelfall nicht
überprüfen können
insgesamt aber deswegen werden gemacht
und Studien viel Probanden und daraus
haben sie dann irgendwann eine ganz
Deutschland dass wir andere Seite
nein nein nein nein nein nein nein was
anderes
verfolgen Sie doch einmal verfolgen sie
einmal die Geschichte der Einführung des
Medikaments am Anfang sollte es die
Infektion verhindern dann sollte es die
Übertragung verhindern dann wurden
weitere Kriterien angeführt die alle
nicht gestimmt haben es gab die er den
R-Wert dann gab es die Parole flatten
the curve wenn es nicht weitergehen kann
für den Fachleuten leider auch ihren
Kollegen immer etwas ein und die letzte
rückzugsposition die wir jetzt haben die
aus statistisch und
experimentell nicht Nachweis nachweisbar
ist dass es schwere Verläufe verhindert
das kann man überhaupt nicht feststellen
weil bei demjenigen der Schere Verlauf
verhindert wurde müsste man
logischerweise das ganze noch mal in
Gang setzen ohne die Impfung ich kenne
Leute die viermal geimpft wurden schwer
krank sind
vielleicht Glück gehabt andere nicht
und Wissenschaftler
die argumentieren diesen Satz alle
Wissenschaftler der ist schon in der
Klima Debatte vollkommen alle wissen sie
sondern Wissenschaftler
gesagt
über dem Lehrbuch drin aber der Punkt
ist sie wollen zahlen haben ja man hat
immer versucht diese Zahlen zu
verhindern zum Beispiel diese Impfstoff
Stute von Herrn Professor mattis in von
der Charité als er es war die einzige
einigermaßen brauchbare prospektive
Studie dazu der hat rausgekriegt jeder
jeder 140 hat schwere Nebenwirkung da
wurde dann wurde er diskriminiert und
von der Charity Mund totgestellt ich
meine rechnen Sie mal die Zahlen hoch
das immer bei etwa 800.000 schweren
Nebenwirkung ich glaube das auch und der
Punkt ist einfach der was was sie gerade
gesagt haben sie
ignorieren den
gesetzesverstoßen zu tun ist die die
machen einfach die die machen ihren Job
nicht obwohl es das gesetzlich
vorgeschrieben ist und das wird vom
Parlament einfach nicht thematisiert sie
lachen ich habe die mir die Debatte
angeschaut vom 60 Dezember sie lachen
denjenigen ins Gesicht die auf diesen
Gesetzesbruch hinweisen und damit sage
ich noch mal lachen sie meinen
impfopfern ins Gesicht und das ist nicht
viel aber gar nicht gelacht durch ich
habe auch keinem ich habe genau die
Abgeordneten mir angeschaut diese
witzige gerissen haben darüber hat das
über die Zahlen vom Herrn Lausen die
nämlich sehr wohl war die sind ja sie
haben einfach ihn als als
datenzahler fest also ich habe gesagt
das war der hat immer der Sorge hat
glaube ich
auf jeden Fall Katastrophe ist noch
immer nicht vorbei das hat der Kanzler
jetzt gesagt echt auf ihre
Lieblingsveranstaltung Herr Bruder
lieblingsveranstaltungen drin
gerade die Mächtigen und alle wichtigen
Menschen dieser Welt zusammen doch
Henrik ein Bruder ist das
keine wichtige Veranstaltung im
Gegenteil im Gegenteil wissen Sie ich
wollte nur noch ein Wort zum Glauben und
Wissen sagen natürlich gibt es ein
Zusammenhang zwischen Glauben und Wissen
man kann mit dem Glauben anfangen und
dann wissen enden aber hier geht es um
mehr als Glauben und Wissen hier geht es
darum dass Leute angesichts dieser
Katastrophe die ist ja wirklich gibt
irgendetwas haben müssen was sie tröstet
und dieser trostübungen sind Überfluss
hier gespendet worden man hat in der Tat
leute Leute
die kritische Anmerkungen gemacht haben
wir Frank und ich und wir von der Achse
und andere die hat man zu Corona leugnen
erklärt und der Ursprung gemacht
guten Fuß stehen egal themenwechselt
nicht so sagen
ja also es gibt Weltwirtschaftsforum ich
bin mal wieder nicht eingeladen worden
ich hätte gerne meinen
Migrationshintergrund in den Vordergrund
geschoben aber ich glaube konkreter war
schon da nun gut die hatte doch dass ich
nicht habe und jetzt gehen wir die
üblichen Spekulationen oder so das
Weltwirtschaftsforum deswegen ganz kurz
gegründet 1991 und 1971 Entschuldigung
von Klaus Schwab denn gebildeter Mann
ist er hat einen Doktor in
Betriebswirtschaft und
Ingenieurwissenschaften und inzwischen
ist das hat die sogar die liberale
Situation geschrieben inzwischen das
ganze in der Hose Form einen
Gelddruckmaschine der Apparat setzt 390
Millionen Dollar im Jahr um ist ein
Familienbetrieb geführt geleitet
organisiert von Klaus Schwab seine
Ehefrau und den beiden Kindern also ein
richtiges Familienunternehmen mit 800
Mitarbeitern wenn sie auf die Website
des Wortes Forum gehen gibt's eine
kleine Selbstdarstellung unser finden
Sie den Satz committed to improving the
state of the world wir verpflichten uns
den Zustand der Welt zu verbessern nicht
etwa den Zustande Nahverkehrsmittel im
in Westfalen oder sowas nein das muss
gleich der Zustand der Welt sein das ist
halt die Sprache der Leute die sich für
Experten halten ich habe eine Allergie
gegen Experten experten erklären einem
heute was gestern passieren musste aber
sie nicht imstande heute zu sagen was
morgen passieren könnte und sie haben
diesen riesigen Auflauf dort an Experten
die sich dort mit ihrem Wissen mehr oder
weniger präsentieren im Prinzip im
Prinzip ist das eine Art von Karneval
für die gebildeten Stände und die
wundere mich dass die Medien diesen
Zirkus diesen zusammenkommen eine solche
Aufmerksamkeit schenken nur weil da
prominente Namen dabei sind und auf der
anderen Seite das ist mir das genauso
witzig entstehen wieder
Verschwörungstheorien das heißt die
geheime Elite ist die die Welt lenken
also wenn das geheime Elite ist in die
Welt lenkt dann kann ich nur sagen
Hessen sogar sind sie nicht und dann
sind sie noch völlig unbegabt
aber in der Tat hat das seit eine
gewisse Ähnlichkeit mit Corona der ganze
Zirk das ganze Verfahren ist ja
unglaublich so albern und so dumm wie
der weltklima-gipfel wo die Leute mit
einem Jets angerauscht kommen und dann
müssen die Jets weiter fliegen bei den
Kopenhagen dürfen sie nicht parken es
war nicht genug Platz da in diesem
ägyptischen Dorf dessen Namen nicht
vergessen habe
weggeflogen werden also das sind reine
Fenster Schau Schaufenster
Veranstaltungen die nichts bringen und
wirklich viel kosten ähm was ich dann
noch dazu gerne sagen wollte zu den
Eliten das sind keine Eliten das sind
Leute die auf irgendeine Weise Erfolg
hatten sich durch große Leistungen nicht
auszeichnen das geht auch während Vater
intelligentesten gehört ich habe mir
ausgedruckt welche Ordner bekommen hat
und man kann die Leute auch daran messen
ob ihr schon im bundesverdienst gehabt
haben oder nicht er hat inzwischen drei
außerdem hat er das große Goldene
Ehrenzeichen für Verdienst um der
Republik Österreich wahrscheinlich keine
Topfenknödel von milliampstrudel
unterscheiden er ist Ehrenbürger der
Landschaft Davos klein kein Wunder er
hat auch den Orden der Freundschaft
Kasachstan was ich am besten finde ist
der Orden vom aztekischen Adler in
Mexiko dann gibt es eine Liste seine
Veröffentlichungen hat neuen Bücher
veröffentlicht davon einige auch nur als
herausgegeben
sie heute gerne im kleinen Schweizer
Berg das natürlich sind sie am liebsten
in diesem Tisch davon gehe ich
aussetzen würden Sie gerne in der wusste
dabei sein diese Woche Bundestagssitzung
und da bin ich natürlich
teilweise die Kritik weil gerade bei der
Klimakonferenz hat man das gesehen da
kommen dann wirklich viele
Klimaschützer oder solche die sich so
nennen und genau
Gesundheitsministerium CO2 in die Luft
geblasen und wenn am Ende nicht viel bei
rauskommt dann ist das tatsächlich
kontraproduktiv trotzdem ist es
natürlich grundsätzlich wichtig dass es
auch irgendwo Formate gibt bei den
Staatschefs Regierungschefs andere die
in der Wirtschaft oder in Unternehmen
Einfluss haben auch miteinander sprechen
das würde ich jetzt nicht grundsätzlich
kritisch sehen aber es muss natürlich
was bei rauskommen insofern würde ich
immer dann sagen an ihren Taten solltet
ihr sie dann messen und wenn da was
richtig gutes bei rauskommt dann kann
man das hat sich gelohnt wenn das aber
nur eine ja quasselrunde ist bei der
nichts rauskommt dann hat sich das Ganze
nicht gelogen
Hunde oder glauben Sie es kommt was bei
raus wenn so viele Menschen die in der
Welt großen Einfluss haben
zusammenkommen grundsätzlich ist das
immer keine schlechte Idee aber die
Widersprüche sind aber den Händen zu
greifen und humoristisch sie zu nehmen
ist wohl die beste Art und Weise
allerdings ich habe es ernst gemeint
stimmt entschuldigung aber allerdings
bleibt mir Sachen dann noch ein bisschen
im Hals stecken wenn ich mir zum
Beispiel mit was er da so von sich gibt
ja er hat sich dann mit den ähm Leuten
den architekton auch des corona-hypes
getroffen zum Beispiel Jeremy Fahrrad
und äh fantasiert von dem jahrhundert
der Pandemien also sie wollen das
multiplizieren und das ganze ging los
diese ganze dieser ganze Lobby
Geschichte ging los vor 25 Jahren mit
Corona Forschung und damit auch gegen
mittelforschung zu den entsprechenden
manipulierten Viren und jetzt Frau
Schubert was glauben Sie denn wer das
Ganze vor 25 Jahren gestartet da wäre es
finanziert hat diese ganzen
corona-forschung und mRNA
impfstoffforschung wer hat das
finanziert so ich sind sagen
Friedenspartei was im Hintergrund
gewesen ja und das sollten Sie hellhörig
werden vor was für ein Karren sie sich
haben spannen lassen und die machen
nämlich da gerade so weiter und das
greift auch mein Thema wieder auf wenn
wir eine funktionierende
Arzneimittelsicherheit hätten dann würde
das nicht möglich sein aber sie haben
sie mit Corona geschrottet
wenn sie direkt darauf angesprochen Frau
Schubert also nach meinem Informationen
stammt wurde viel Forschung für ein
Krebser für eine krebsimpfung gemacht
und wurden Erkenntnisse aus dieser
Forschung
für für den corona-impfstoff genutzt ich
bin keine Medizinerin ich bin keine
Pharmazeutin ich kann das letztendlich
überhaupt nicht beurteilen ich habe mich
auf das zu verlassen was die Fachleute
im Auftrag der Regierung und sagen als
Parlamentarierin weil in die politischen
Entscheidungen wir ja dann als
Parlamentarier auch zu vertreten haben
und dann werde ich mich in irgendwelche
verschwörungsmythen nicht verstricken
aber ich dachte jetzt geht's eigentlich
um um diese um den um Davos oder die
Frage ob solche Formate sinnvoll sind
Klimaschutz steht ganz oben
Klimaschutz zu organisieren ich sag ganz
ehrlich ich finde es befremdlich dass
solche Treffen privatwirtschaftlich
organisiert werden weil wenn sich
regierungs-
als Ministerinnen und Minister treffen
dann gibt es da eigentlich andere
Formate in dem das sinnvoll ist also die
Vereinten Nationen die OSZE aber nicht
in privates Hotel oder ein privater
Wirtschaftsmann
das finde ich auf jeden Fall den den
sinnvolleren Rahmen deswegen teile ich
nicht die Kritik am am klima-gipfel ich
glaube das ist notwendig ist dass sich
die die Regierung dieser dieser Welt
zusammensetzen und überlegen wie kann
man die Klimaziele einhalten weil
letztendlich steht die Zukunft dieses
Planeten auf dem Spiel die den großen
Kippung werden wir alle hier an diesem
also die vielleicht noch aber an der
Rest an diesem Tisch alle nicht mehr
erleben aber diejenigen die wir in die
Welt gesetzt haben und der Nachfolge die
werden Sie erleben und die verantwortung
heißt dass wir irgendwie in der
tatsächlich in allen Ländern an allen
Hebeln jetzt reden müssen oder ziehen
müssen um diesen Klimawandel zu
entschleunigen um einen anderen Vater
eine andere Logik einzuschlagen und
alles was da an Gesprächen gibt die
tatsächlich dann auch zu konkreten
Ergebnissen zu konkreten Maßnahmen
führen diese die sind mir sehr lieb und
sehr teuer weil ich glaube
den Gefallen kann ich Ihnen leider nicht
tun ich gehe aus einem schlichten Grund
nicht mit weil dieser wenn Sie so wollen
Kultur der treffen hat er nicht vor vier
Wochen begonnen das gab schon vor 50 60
Jahren der Klappe from hat genau das
passiert sagen schon von 50 60 Jahren
veröffentlicht und gehen ihre Ressourcen
aus um das Jahr 200 2000 wird das nicht
mehr genug Rohstoffe geben all diese
utopischen oder distopischen Vorhersagen
sind nicht eingetroffen und was den
Klimawandel geht die Debatte will ich
jetzt nicht weiterführen
es ist ein Horrorszenario das ganze ist
eine Frage der Religiosität je weniger
Leute an Gott glauben umso mehr Leute
glauben sie können Gott spielen sie
wollen das kriegen den Klimawandel
entschleunigen Mutten sich dann etwas zu
viel zu den Klimawandel entschleunigen
glauben sie vor uns hat kein Klimawandel
gegeben es hat immer Klimawandel
gegangen die Frage ist nur ob die Erde
bewohnbar bleibt oder ob sie zumindest
in Teilen unbewohnbar bleibt
von der mächtigen Politik hin zurück zur
Basis sind viele Menschen können ihre
Miete nicht mehr bezahlen und dieses
Thema gehen wir einfach nur kurzen Pause
hier bei 8:15 Uhr bleiben Sie gerne bei
uns
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein das ist doch völlig
realitätsfernsehen unheimlich wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruinieren
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glückler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst
haben wir haben zu viel Stahl wegfallen
und wir uns gegenseitig in Berlin Mitte
Cappuccinos verkaufen das funktioniert
nicht dann ist alles essen als Freiheit
würde ich sagen das muss jedem erlaubt
sein
wenn ihr Opfer und um Währungen von
Menschen unser Land fordert dann müsst
ihr bei euch anfangen da muss doch was
machbar sein ich finde aber diese
gesamte Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch
ein bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt über dem Gerät
[Musik]
nach fünf
wohnen ist teuer geworden ganz viele
Menschen fürchten dass sie ihre Miete
gar nicht mehr bezahlen können da müssen
dringend neue Lösungen Herr kettiner
Schubert ist bei uns von den Linken und
glaubt eine Lösung parat zu haben ihre
Zeit ihr Thema ja vielen Dank jeder
Mensch braucht ein Zuhause das ist
sozusagen genauso wichtig wie der Zugang
zur Arbeit zu Bildung zu Gesundheit zu
Energie und wenn wir in der Lage kommen
dass Menschen die jetzt nicht so
wahnsinnig viel verdienen ihre Wohnungen
nicht mehr bezahlen können ihre Miete
nicht mehr bezahlen können die
Nebenkosten nicht mehr zu bezahlen
können dann ist stark gefordert dort
entsprechend einzugreifen die
Bundesregierung hatte ja große Pläne
400.000 Wohnungen pro Jahr sollten
gebaut werden das hat sie nicht
geschafft hat sie nicht annähernd
geschafft und das hat dramatische Folgen
vor allen Dingen hat sich im sozialen
Wohnungsbau nicht geschafft jedes Jahr
gegen mehr soziale Wohnungen
Sozialwohnungen raus aus der Förderung
aus der Bindung als Sozialwohnungen als
neue hinzukommen und um das zu stoppen
sind wir der festen Überzeugung dass wir
eine neue wohngemeinnützigkeit brauchen
und dass wir
kommunale Wohnungsbaugesellschaften
brauchen die wir hier zum Beispiel in
Berlin haben die ist aber auch in vielen
anderen Gemeinden und in vielen anderen
Ländern gibt die verstärkt soziale
Wohnungen und Sozialwohnungen bauen die
verstärkt auch entsprechend ausgestattet
werden damit sie das finanzieren können
um so Wohnungen anbieten zu können die
auch tatsächlich für jeden Geldbeutel
bezahlbar sind und das kann man
natürlich Staffeln je nach je nach nach
Einkommen aber wir sind da Auffassung
niemand soll mehr als 30% seines
Einkommens für die Wohnung für die Miete
zahlen müssen weil es braucht ja noch
mehr im Leben als nur zu wohnen wobei
wohnen wirklich ein ein ganz zentrale
ganz zentrale
Angelegenheit ist wenn man kein Zuhause
hat dann ist man unsicher dann fühlt man
sich nicht wohl dann hat man eigentlich
auch keine Chance im Beruf erfolgreich
zu sein oder in der Bildung erfolgreich
zu sein dann bleibt
die Lösung ist das die Lösung der Start
baut Wohnungen vermietet die günstiger
ich glaube nicht dass man mit dem Staat
überträgt kann eine Lösung sein weil der
Starter das ja verkaufst ich bin
vollkommen ihrer Meinung ausnahmsweise
dass das Wohnen eines der wichtigsten
Bedürfnisse ist dass man dem Markt auch
nicht überlassen kann aber hier gibt es
ein Staatsversagen der Berliner Senat
will jetzt die Wohnungen zurückkaufen
die er selber vor 20 Jahren verkauft hat
zu sehr ungünstigen Bedingungen und das
ist nicht nur in Berlin so und Sie
werden keine Erleichterung finden wenn
Sie die Aufgaben im Staat übertragen es
wird nur länger dauern und mehr Kosten
vom Staat ich rede von kommunalen
Wohnung ich sage eingreifen aber naja es
sind aber Unternehmen die werden wir
Unternehmen geführt also schauen Sie
sich mal hier gerade wenn sie sind ja
auch aus Berlin schauen Sie sich mal
hier um die sechs landeseigenen
Wohnungsbaugesellschaften arbeiten sehr
genau und die Arbeiten auch
wirtschaftlich und sind trotzdem in der
Lage bezahlbaren Wohnraum
bereitzustellen da sind wo sie recht
haben
es wird zurzeit viel weniger gebaut als
je ja weil aber deswegen sagen wir ja
auch wir müssen den Schwerpunkt auf den
kommunalen Wohnungsbau legen weil die
privaten sicher vom Bau zurückgezogen
haben das lohnt sich für Sie im Moment
auch seine Verschiebung der
Verantwortung die Baukosten sind
gestiegen die Zinsen sind gestiegen die
privaten bauen keine Sozialwohnungen nur
10% der Förderung die wir hier im Land
Berlin bereitstellen gehen an private
die beantragen ist gar nicht weil es
sich für sie nicht lohnt Sozialwohnungen
zu bauen weil
ich bitte deswegen sagen
wir müssen die Förderung die wir haben
und noch mehr unseren landeseigenen
Wohnungsbaugesellschaften unseren
Genossenschaften zur Verfügung stellen
damit sie günstig Kredite bekommen
Bundesländern gehen hier in Berlin wird
genau das machen
also Berlin ist ja gerade dabei Spiel
wie es nicht funktioniert sollte also
sie haben hier in Berlin mietendeckel
eingeführt und gesagt immer mehr
Sozialismus und immer mehr mit linker
Politik wenn man wenn man diese will man
diese Probleme lösen das Ergebnis war
das Ergebnis
das Ergebnis Frau Schubert war dass die
Wohnungsbau Zahlen massiv eingebrochen
sind es gab immer mehr immer weniger
Wohnung es stehen hier hunderte Leute
vor einer Wohnung wenn die mal frei ist
alle wollen rein und in anderen Städten
da sieht es deutlich besser aus wenn man
darauf andere Ansätze gesetzt hat dann
hat man alle an da hat man alle anderen
und man hat überlegt
einen großen Städten im Moment ausschaut
Berlin
[Musik]
immer ein bisschen mehr in die Realität
holen ich möchte einmal hören sie sind
eher im ländlichen
einmal zuzuhören ja im ländlichen
Bereich ihre Praxis war schön an ihnen
die Menschen gibt ist es dort anders
sind und viele Menschen die Existenz
gibt natürlich auch Wohnprobleme
Studenten also es ist natürlich eine
Katastrophe ich sehe auch in meiner
eigentlichen Heimatstadt das ist eine
kleine Odenwald Gemeinde was ein
riesiges Baugebiet erschlossen wurde wo
ausgelost wurde nach social Credit
Points sehr wer jetzt im Bauplatz
bekommt und was ist alle haben fast alle
haben zurückgezogen ja weil also die
Preise zu hoch geworden sind also ich
glaube das ist alles auch ein Problem
dass die Leute einfach auch zu wenig
Geld haben und Reise explodiert und das
real,-
ich meine das ist jetzt nicht mein
Fachgebiet und soweit ich sehe halt nur
dass in Deutschland glaube ich der
Wohlstand zurückgeht und ich das ist das
muss
recht da sind natürlich die Schere geht
auseinander definitiv und ist Folge von
sie dort auch die Schere die auseinander
geht in ihrer Praxis beispielsweise das
ist schon dass ich schon zu spüren ja
und es wird es wird schwieriger es wird
schwieriger für die Leute einfach
genügend übrig zu haben dass sie
vielleicht noch richtig was klein ist
dann zum Schluss leisten können das wird
immer schwieriger werden es gab auch
dass man eine Entwicklung haben die das
noch problematischer macht und das ist
ich darf es einfach nur so eine Runde
werfen ich bin aber da jetzt wirklich
kein Experte das ist Folge von von
schlechter Politik ja also auf den
Wohlstand der Bürger zu achten und und
das die die Chance haben sich etwas
aufzubauen das ist im Zeichen von guter
Politik und man sieht ja schon
unterschiedlich in Deutschland also wir
haben hier in Berlin ein großes
Wohnungsproblem das Leben natürlich auch
an das liegt natürlich vor allem auch am
rot rot grün Senat der ihm gesagt hat
und es soll alle staatlich zugeteilt
werden die alternativ Antwort wäre dass
sie sich Gedanken gemacht hätten wie
kann das Angebot an Wohnung vergrößert
werden das ist dann Marktwirtschaft und
dadurch würden die Preise Denken und die
Menschen hätten einfacher die
Möglichkeit eine Wohnung zu bekommen
Mensch natürlich nicht nur ihre Mieten
zahlen sondern auch ihre Nebenkosten
zahlen und das muss noch mal eingreifen
irgendwie für Kleinkinder ja man muss
nur genug bauen dann wird dann werden
die Preise schon sinken das ist falsch
wenn die Privaten nicht bereit sind
haben Sie früher auch anders gedacht
aber naja ähm wenn wenn
du willst
dann müssen wir über kommunale
Unternehmen Sozialwohnungen bauen damit
jeder eine entsprechende Wohnung
das ist kein Berliner Spezifikum sondern
das ist in der ganzen
bundesrepublikation gehört muss ich
sagen
also es bleibt trotzdem müssen sie ihre
Zeit jetzt ist die CDU nämlich großer
Fan von Atomkraft und sogar wie ich
jetzt gelesen Beschluss wurde verschickt
bemerkenswert ist der Neubau von
Atomkraftwerken ist vorurteilsfrei zu
prüfen wie kam es zu der Entwicklung
erklären Sie uns jetzt also wie können
die Strompreise in Deutschland wieder
sinken wie können wir die
Klimaschutzziele erreichen das sind
wichtige Fragen die die Politik und die
unsere Gesellschaft angehen sollten und
neben dem Ausbau der Erneuerer
Erneuerbaren brauchen wir weitere Form
der Energieerzeugung und wir haben
derzeit in Deutschland noch
funktionierende Kernkraftwerke die über
10 Millionen Haushalte mit Strom
versorgen und deswegen finde ich es
unglaublich dass die Ampelkoalition
plant das im Frühjahr Kernenergie nicht
mehr zum Einsatz kommen soll wir
brauchen die Kernkraftwerke auf deswegen
weil sie eine CO2 neutrale Form der
Energieerzeugung sind und deswegen mein
Plädoyer wir brauchen die Kernenergie
auch über das früher hinaus wir brauchen
Kernenergie aus sozial gründen um die
Preise zu senken und wir brauchen
Kernenergie auch damit wir die
Klimaschutzziele erreichen können Herr
bloss wie kam es zu dieser Wende erst
den Atomausstieg beschlossen dann den
auch noch unterstützt jetzt öffnet man
sich traut sich aber glaube ich noch
nicht so ganz vielleicht selbst erneut
der Kernenergie auch als vor über zehn
Jahren in Deutschland da andere
Entscheidung getroffen wurden genau aber
damals hat man gesagt okay neben
Erneuerbaren setzen wir auf Gas so das
war eigentlich auch zwischen ein
Parteien dann Einigkeit da und jetzt
haben wir aber nach dem russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine natürlich
eine ganz andere Situation das ist für
die sogenannte grundleskapazität also
wenn es jetzt hier im Januar wenig Sonne
gibt wenig Wind gibt dann können wir
nicht nur auf erneuerbare setzen
deswegen müssen wir in Deutschland die
Frage erklären was brauchen wir für die
Grundlast und da gibt's jetzt nur noch
Kohle oder Kern Energie und Kohle ist
mit die klimaschädlichste Form der
Energieerzeugung und deswegen sage ich
ganz klar wir brauchen gerne
an der CDU in der Regierung hätten wir
in zehn Jahren noch Atomkraft wir Herr
wir haben im Deutschen Bundestag
beantragt dass die Laufzeiten verlängert
werden erstmal für einige Jahre und ich
glaube persönlich auch dass wir auf
Kernenergie neben Erneuerbaren setzen
müssen weil wir in Deutschland erstmal
wir haben ja einige funktionierende
Kernkraftwerke nein ich bin nein ich bin
erstmal ich bin erstmal für den ersten
Schritt ich bin für den ersten Schritt
nämlich dass die funktionierenden
Kernkraftwerke von denen wir ja einige
in Deutschland noch haben dass die jetzt
nicht alle abgeschaltet werden das würde
uns schon helfen allein die drei
kernkraftwerfen können über 10 Millionen
Haushalten weil sie nämlich wenn man sie
weiterlaufen wollen würde was ich für
grundfalt schalte sie von Grund auf
erneuern und Sanieren müsste das neue
neuer Brennstäbe da rein genau
kein Problem
andere Länder schaffen
und damit hat sich dieser
Preisverteilung sehr allgemein
skandinavischen Staaten alle setzen hat
sich damit auch schon erledigt und im
übrigen es ändert sich ja nichts an der
Tatsache dass Kernenergie eine
brandgefährliche Energie ist wir hatten
mehrere Havarien die viele Menschen
krank gemacht haben
die Alternative sind regenerative
Energien wenn ihre parte nicht über
Jahrzehnte blockiert hätten dann werden
wir schon seine
Parteien
ja warte an der Stromerzeugung waren 65
Prozent der stromerze
zu hören
alle Gäste zu Wort kommen lassen
dr Frank genau also die gewählten
Volksvertreter wie sie ja beide sind
haben wir in der ganzen Sendung jetzt
schon auch gesagt dass sie sich Experten
einladen und Fachleute einladen nicht
empfehlen Ihnen auch mal Fachleute
einzuladen den andere Meinung haben oder
halt wirklich Bescheid wissen z.B
hannover-burg ja das ist ein ein
Atomexperte der kennt die Hälfte aller
Atomkraftwerke in Deutschland in
Deutschland der Welt ja er war
Atomphysiker gewesen eben in der DDR und
lassen sich einfach mal von ihm die
Situation erklären lassen erklären warum
es sein kann dass ein deutscher Physiker
ja
genialer junge Mann einen fantastischen
Reaktor entwickelt hat in dulflutreaktor
ja der auf dem Papier wohlgemerkt es
kommt nicht zum Gau er kann alte
Brennstäbe verbrennen wo wird der jetzt
entwickelt in Kanada warum weil wir in
Deutschland uns angewöhnt haben
Problemlösungen nur noch moralistisch
anzugehen ja jemand der der eine gute
Idee hat der aber dem narrativ nicht
entspricht von Klima oder Corona oder
was auch immer Einwanderung wird
niedergemacht heute in der Universität
ich habe da viele Beispiele auch von
Patienten die Professoren sind an der
Uni Heidelberg und darüber müssen wir
reden wir haben eine vollkommen
Kompetenz und Sache ja feindliche
Umgebung geschaffen in der öffentliche
Diskussionen das ist unser das ist unser
Problem in dem Sinne dafür brauchen wir
alles was Greta sagt nicht doch ein
Wahnsinn und wir haben so tolle Leute in
Deutschland aber sie trauen sich nicht
mehr teilweise die in der Vorlesung
etwas zu sagen weil dann irgendeiner
kommt mit Klima Klimawandel gibt es aber
wenn sie schon begründen dass mehr
Atomkraftwerke brauchen um den
Klimawandel aufzuhalten dann weiß ich
schon das wird nichts ich bedanke mich
ganz herzlich für eine Regel Runde hier
vielen herzlichen Dank an meine Gäste
vielen herzlichen Dank auch an sie fürs
zuschauen das war viertel nach acht
machen sie es gut
[Musik]